[Music]
and today's show we have a hard one
this is all about family relationships
and dealing with family illness and what
happens when we're left out of family
decisions
and what happens when you love someone
who's dealt with trauma and you don't
know what to do next stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
yo yo this is john with the dr john
deloney's show
man i'm glad you're with us
we have a wild show ahead of us i say
that i don't really know what's coming
but it just sounds like a cool thing to
say these days it's going to be wild
i'm glad you're glad you're here man
we're talking about mental health
relationships relational iq
parenting schools everything anything
you can think of give us a shout
1-844-693-3291 this is your show it's
for you by you
go to johndaloni.com
ask and by the way join our newsletter
send something out once a week
and it's not bonkers it's not terrible
it's not me just trying to sell you
stuff it's
cool science it's come out about mental
health it is cool gadget that i think is
great it's something that made me laugh
throughout the week just to bring some
joy
um it's a it's a note of positivity um
and sometimes it's just a personal note
of stuff that i'm seeing or i've
experienced or going through it's a cool
newsletter i don't like newsletters just
as a rule and so i'm trying to be
intentional about making this one
a newsletter that is worth your time
it's not just going to clog up your
inbox go to johndelleny.com
and scroll down to the bottom and put
your email address in there love to have
you on the newsletter list it's pretty
rad
james kelly it's good to see y'all
james that's a lot of denim kel you look
great hope all is good
connor feeling it doing good man
yeah everything's good
this is one of those rare shows it just
feels great today
well just wait two gets to the calls
yeah right wait james can bring down a
room everybody
just kidding
still sad about our loss several months
ago now still can't let it go how did
your recording session go last night
great
what kind of guitar do you use
telecaster oh gosh we had him we had him
kelly old james solving for his
equilibrium is going back he's going to
gain all that weight back he's going to
start listening to
sad jangly music
poetry about dads and playing
telecasters we had him though for a
minute kelly was awesome we did
all right um by the way we have a loaded
um
man the
the audience out there is crazy today
it's good to see everybody there's not a
single person out there not one just
empty chairs it's cool though it's early
in the morning here like on a tuesday so
i don't know i hope people at work
things like that but whatever all right
hey let's go to lynn and raleigh what's
up lynn how's it going
hey um
it's going it's good oh man oh no what's
that mean it's going huh
oh it's just another tuesday in paradise
you know isn't it though hey right at
the um
the audience outside of wherever you are
or is there at least one person out
there i got none um i got a couple of
stuffed animals in the corner does that
count i'm looking at like a a hand
sanitizer bottle so you win
congratulations especially if you've
named them that's pretty great
so what's up
so um
my
dad
is in the beginning to middle stages of
alzheimer's oh lynn i'm sorry how long
so
um
he's been deteriorating for about i'd
say three or four years now but um
but we've
we've sort of known it was coming
because he had so many um
aunts and uncles on his mom's side uh
passive alzheimer's but i mean we've
kind of known for a couple of decades
um but uh it
doesn't make it any easier to watch him
deteriorate right no it's the worst i'm
so sorry
it's weird we're making it is your mom
still around
so my mom
actually one of the fortunate parts of
the story is my mom is 15 years younger
than him so she's uh very much capable
of
uh being at home and helping him along
and taking care of him and stuff like
that so
that that within itself is a blessing
so how can i help i'm so sorry wow um
so
the problem
so i i know this is common um
uh my mom
whoever's living with them right gets
increasingly frustrated with
um all the changes the deterioration the
fact that uh your relatives can no
longer particularly learn new things um
uh and and the forgetfulness and not
knowing what day it is and stuff like
that um
my problem is more with the family
dynamics around this
um so can i have two questions today but
they're related okay talk into the phone
there
yeah there you go
so
i have two questions today they're sort
of related
my
i want to be able to help my mom and
help my dad without
necessarily
taking over jobs that aren't my
responsibility and where where that
concern comes from is
both
my
husband and my brother
have sort of said well look your mom's
always done
whatever the heck she wanted to do
anyway
uh you can't you can't enable her
you've gotta this is her job you can't
move in and take over you can't
like i've got i've got
i've got family that doesn't
particularly trust my mom's capacity in
this and
while at
from the get-go
um
i know where they're coming from but at
the same time i've seen her grow and
change a lot and her um ability
willingness patience
take care of him um and i have to
i have to find a balance between because
i'm i'm totally the person that's like
okay it's fine i'll go over there i can
handle it um
uh you know i'll take care of this i'll
take care of that i'm not gonna follow
through
um
so so let me ask you this lune
what is
what is not getting taken care of that
you need to go solve
give me some give me some specifics
my mom
will my mom has
uh not mom
take mom out of it because when we when
we start answering with well mom
um it ends up getting filtered through
20 or 30 or 40 years of mom
oh yeah i know
and that and that's where this comes
from so put her over to the side what
are the tasks
that aren't getting done that you feel
like i might need to go over there and
people are pressuring you not to some
people are pressing you to do it what
are the things out there that are
floating around that you need to go
solve that you think you need to go
solve be specific
um
i promise this would be putting it on my
mom so bear with me for sure okay
you
will go on weekend trips
um
dad has to stay at home and take care of
pets
dad is not good at being
dad
does no longer is good at being home
alone she will not change she will not
change that portion of her lifestyle um
and
and
that that's where the frustration from
my family members comes from guys well
she's going to keep going off on these
weekend trips
that's not going to change when is she
going to figure out that
um when is she going to figure out that
she can't
do that anymore and so my my
i get
i'm the sibling that's closest to them i
live maybe 20 minutes away um and
and it's easy for me to say well yeah
i'll check in on that right or
yeah i'll spend the week with them or
yeah because that doesn't affect my
commute to work particularly or anything
like that sure um and and that's where
the conflict comes in is well this is
her responsibility she needs to figure
out that you know things are changing
and she just can't go wherever she wants
to miss that and the other have you have
you sat down and talked to her just
y'all too gone to have lunch together
and said hey
the whole family a couple years a year
and a half ago maybe we all sat down
with both of them and said okay um this
is what me and my brother are willing to
do to help you guys along make sure
you're staying in communication so that
we can help with whatever's going on my
mom calls me fairly
maybe a couple times a month to just
sort of go ah your dad's frustrating me
again and like i just let her vent
whatever but in terms of me and her
going out and just sitting down and
saying
you know what's the game plan no i have
not done it okay
so here's a couple of things i think
that are sound like they're they're
circling around
one is
um what are you oldest by the way
youngest middles where are you i am
youngest i'm younger okay yeah but i'm
but i'm also the executor of his escape
so dad i'll be like i'm the one that dad
trusts that's right the responsible baby
so yes very good yeah
um
so
it sounds like
and i may just be off my rocker here
but
it's a nightmare
loving somebody being in a relationship
with somebody who's in the early stages
of alzheimer's and in the middle stages
and at the end
because it's easy to point at the task
they can't remember anything i i need to
run out of town yeah you don't even did
you eat today that kind of thing have
you bathed
that stuff is the surface level
frustration
but the deep
frustration the deep hurt there is
it's like you're hugging somebody and
they just turn to dust underneath you to
sand yeah
and her sense of security and safety is
going going because he's always taking
care of everything exactly right so yeah
so
it's easy to focus on the tasks part and
what happens when we focus on the task
part is we start trying to control stuff
yeah and also one of her coping
mechanisms has has been a certain amount
of escapism so i understand from wanting
to get away yeah
so there's escapism and then there's
reality right so
i want
i would love to see i i mean i say i
want this is for you guys i would love
to see you
take your mom out you'll have the big
family meeting which every family needs
to do
and then there's the reality 18 months
later
yeah
and hey mom
like are you you're married right
yes okay now you can speak to her in a
in this is weird
relational dynamics when this stuff
shifts
um
but hey mom i can't imagine what it'd be
like to begin to slowly
like my husband slowly turned to smoke
in my hands
yeah how are you
and not an eventy he did he spilled dog
food everywhere or what
but a
a a human thing right
yeah
and
from there say
that's when you can that will be the
bridge to
you're going out of town a lot if we're
going to start going out of town i feel
like we need to make a plan
and sometimes i can be there and
sometimes i cannot
and we've got to be realistic about what
these things look like and
begin to have human conversations not
solution oriented problem solving but
human does that and i know i sound like
i'm i'm i'm
semantics here but you hear all one is
one is relational in nature and one is
who's gonna make sure the bill gets paid
both need to happen but i think your mom
desperately needs you to talk to her as
a fellow woman as a fellow wife and say
i cannot believe this is happening
underneath you and i'm so sorry
and there's a reality here
the second part is is that i think
everybody in your family is trying to
love you the best they know how to do
and nobody's being super helpful
so
boy that's my like well and here here's
the thing you as the youngest as the
problem solver and the police are all
wrapped up into one beautiful wonderful
woman
are trying to make sure everything is
taken care of and make sure everybody is
okay with how you're taking care of it
and that's not how this is gonna play
and so i'd love to see you and your
husband get away for a minute whether
that's a half a day go somewhere and i
say that all the time just clear the
deck and say yeah i know it sounds cool
to say this is my mom's job but that's
my dad
and i've got about a year left where
he's gonna even recognize me anymore and
so i'm gonna lean into that in this
season
and husband i need you to be okay with
that
yeah and that's i've i've started doing
trying to do things with him that
enjoys before he can't enjoy them
anymore um but you gotta you gotta be
you gotta be clear with your husband
about that otherwise he's gonna be angry
at your mother-in-law his mother-in-law
your mom he's gonna be angry at your dad
because he's gonna feel like you all
took my wife from me
and that's different than you looking at
him saying i got about a year left with
my dad
and
i'm gonna miss him forever and i want to
soak up every last moment he looks at he
recognizes me
and that's a different thing for your
husband
and that's him living in he'll be
frustrated
but he will
love you in a way it's a deeper
connective does that make sense
yeah it does make that so
and be clear with your brother and
sister because it's it's a it's a moment
where you as the executor you as the
young youngest are gonna reverse
engineer this whole thing you are not
doing things to make everybody happy
anymore you're doing things to deal with
relationships to deal with reality
and that's gonna be you co-creating this
with your husband and then you saying
here's what this is going to look like
and just know
this gets messy
mom may disappear
mom may completely abandon this whole
thing or she may like you said she may
turn into the most extraordinary
caregiver that nobody expected
your brother and sister who's been so
awesome and so such mentors you know
they may turn into complete idiots
because they don't know what to deal
with
your dad one of them already did exactly
they will and then but as you say that's
another phone call well they're gonna
get they're gonna get um
they're gonna get
they're gonna feel ashamed that their
younger sister's
taken over all this and so they're gonna
blame you for it they're gonna blame mom
you can't control any of that
you can control two things
your thoughts the way you love your dad
the way you decide to think about your
mom the way you decide to take about
your husband and your actions
that's it
and those actions are i'm gonna be this
clear this direct i'm gonna follow this
plan i'm gonna have this conversation
with my mom this one with my husband and
then i'm gonna tell my brother and
sister here's what we're doing
and i'm gonna soak up the moments i can
with my dad and i'm gonna not feel
guilty when i gotta go to work or deal
with my own kids
i'm going to take this control of this
thing from the head up and by the way
you're right mom's
your mom's job is to take care of her
husband that is this is her
responsibility and so you're an adjunct
to that you are not the caretaker
and when you get an impetus to control
stuff i want you to back down
and ask your body what are you trying to
solve here
is there an issue is dad not eating do i
need to go feed the dog or
am i so sad and scared that i'm losing
my dad right in front of my eyes i'm
watching him just disappear and that's
heartbreaking you gotta sit in that
grief because you can't solve that
you gotta own it you gotta sit in it
you gotta hold that old man's hand and
tell him you love him even as he slowly
the the
the recognition slowly leaves his eyes
and it's hard and that's why alzheimer's
is it it's just evil it's the worst
that's why he's so lucky to have you
lynn so lucky to have you
hey we'll be right back on the dr john
dolone show
hey what's up this delony let's talk
about getting a good night's sleep it's
important for your physical health your
mental health your relation health for
your sanity you name it sleep is
important if you're not sleeping good
one of the first questions i want you to
ask is do i need a new mattress
here's how you tell are you tossing and
turning all night because you can't get
comfortable are you waking up in the
middle of the night burning hot or in
the morning does your back hurt if you
have any of these issues you may need a
new mattress
check out dream cloud it's a mattress i
have in my own house you will love it
and they're currently running their
biggest offer of all time
400 bucks in accessories plus an
additional 250 discount only for deloney
listeners that's a total of 650 bucks in
accessories and savings visit
dreamcloudsleep.com
or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get a new mattress shipped to
your house today and you can enjoy 650
bucks in savings that's
dreamcloudsleep.com promo code
all right we're back let's go to lisa in
dayton ohio hey lisa what's going on
hey dr john how are you remarkable how
we doing
good good um so i'll just jump into it
um my husband's mom was diagnosed with
stage four brain cancer earlier this
summer oh my gosh
seriously
yeah it's been a little rough out of the
blue
um yeah sort of um there was like a
month where they thought she had a
stroke and then she had another stroke
and then they finally
um diagnosed the cancer and it wasn't a
stroke at all lisa i'm so sorry
she she's pretty wonderful woman
uh yeah yeah i'd definitely say so
i'm so sorry that's the worst man man
man
oh so this is just a few months old
so yeah man
can only imagine what y'all are going
through so um how can i help
so basically we've been kind of having
some weird family dynamic issues yep
um go figure and basically we feel like
we're being left out in terms of like
assisting
with her care okay um
sorry this is hard i'm nervous
well number one don't be nervous because
the advice i'm gonna give you is about
worth what you pay for it so that's all
good
uh and
yeah and man i just can tell you love
that woman and you love your husband as
he said as i'll get out
yeah
that's hard to yeah hold
the heartbroken hand of someone we love
too wow
yeah
okay so y'all being left out does he
have a sister that's just trying to take
over everything
uh yeah
man i should do this for a living
um so he's the middle he has an older
brother and a younger sister um
and essentially ever since the diagnosis
can i guess this is so rude can i guess
older brothers trying to flex
and tell everybody like this is just and
then sister's just trying to run
everything am i right i could be way off
um sister yes but brother older brother
is kind of like
him and his brother are kind of the same
and they don't like confrontation so
they're just kind of like backing off ah
okay
um and so i can't necessarily speak for
his brother's household because i'm not
there
um but it just seems to us like ever
since she's been in the hospital in and
out with surgeries and everything there
was never like an initial
uh family meeting or like this is how
we're gonna proceed with everything
um there was never any talk of like
maybe we should get a second opinion or
maybe go somewhere that's more
specialized
um basically his sister and his her
his dad
um have decided
how to handle her care and haven't
really really been letting anybody in on
that yeah
um
so the texts like they created a group
text for example and it was only the
siblings none of the spouses were
included
but then i got upset because the
sister's husband got included because
he's a nurse and so they think it's
valuable that his
he's up to date on everything
um and then
we weren't sure what to do so we offered
some help by setting up a gofundme to
help with like medical expenses
um and so i was texting his sister back
and forth
about details to put on the gofundme
page
and basically it came out that
they weren't really letting the boys in
on all the information because they just
didn't seem like they cared
yeah
so here's what i tell you this okay lisa
and this is me giving everybody the
benefit of the doubt let's try how i try
to live my life
your father-in-law
is
everything in this world is
upside down
and everything in your sister-in-law's
world is upside down and when our worlds
get turned upside down we just start
trying to solving problems the best we
can
and it doesn't always bring out the best
in people
and
we start projecting onto other people we
start blaming other people because we
hurt so bad
and we can't possibly blame mom for this
hurt because she's got cancer so we're
gonna blame brother we're gonna bring
blame brother's wife we're gonna blame
brothers little kids we're gonna blame
some doctor and some thing we're gonna
blame the internet whatever it is
and so
then people start communicating via text
then all the the communication gets lost
in translation there's email change sent
around all that stuff you nailed it at
the very beginning
one of the brothers needs to call a
family meeting
we're getting in the car and we're
driving down do you all live in the same
community
we all do like 10 minutes from each
other yes and so
i i'm going to
back out
and say
if this
i'm going to say this in a way that's
going to sound like i'm coming after
your husband and i'm not but i'm i'm
hitting the pendulum all the way to the
other side okay
um well actually let me say it this way
i had a buddy call who i love
known him for a long time
was complaining about his ex-wife and
was frustrated by his ex-wife
and how she's been treating their child
they share together
didn't know this was going on ex-wife
screwed this up ex-wife screwed that up
and i finally said where were you
and this is somebody i love
that phone got quiet i said where are
you
because you're doing a lot of blaming
that's your kid too
and so we went he went over there and
had a discussion with his parents and
basically said we're here to help in any
way but like we don't know your schedule
you have to kind of tell us what you
need that's right um and we still
got nothing like they came over the
other day and they
told us that for the last three weeks
they've been scrambling trying to find
people to take her to appointments
because the person that they had lined
up got sick but never once did they call
did when your husband asked them why
didn't you call what'd they say
they just said like well we didn't ask
him why didn't it call we just we just
said oh i said we would be available if
you need something and they just kind of
looked at us like
i i don't know it was
so i think it's really wise if at all
possible
i'm gonna give you the optimistic side
and the pessimistic side the optimistic
side
is
getting everybody in the same place at
the same time
and one of the kids
needs to step up and say we've been um
we need to all be on the same page here
everybody here is available our spouses
are a part of this thing
they're not going to be excluded
and we're all here to help mom we're all
here to help dad we're all here to help
one another because it's gonna be hard
for everybody
no more games no more texts no more this
isn't that
and
coming up with a meal
thing with a
here's what the doctors are saying we're
going to go to as many appointments
whatever y'all are going to agree on it
has to be said in the same room with the
same people
and
no martyr syndrome no i only have to do
this and that and all that kind of stuff
this is where this is and that's what
that's the response i've been getting
from her is just i'm the one that's
mom's closest person and i'm the one
that should just take all this burden
and blah blah blah and my my concern is
that down the line when all this is said
and done
she's going to use that against him yeah
and here's the thing
she might
she might
and you can't do anything about her
hiding information from you you can't do
anything about her
trying to use the situation to prop
herself up you can't do anything about
that
and so what i'm going to tell you lee
says you're going to make yourself
bonkers
in the middle of a really tragic
situation
trying to solve for your sister-in-law
acting like a four-year-old
my guess is there is
years of sibling dynamics here
and that are coming to play that always
does
and
your husband can tell you stuff all day
long and your brother-in-law can take
stuff all day long but you weren't there
with how they treated your their sister
and how your sister treated them and how
mom all that stuff comes up to play in
this mess
that's why a clearing the deck
making sure
your in-laws know we are here for you
and then after that if they choose to
not call you it will hurt like bloody
hell
and you can't do anything about it
it will be heartbreaking and that's the
choice they chose to make
and the piece you will have is we
reached out we did everything we needed
to do
we kept going over and mowing the yard
we called every morning and said is
there anything we can do to help today
is there we're not going to go to war
with my sister-in-law i'm just not going
to do it i'm going to fight you over
this
over who cares about mom the most i'm
not going to do that
all right every day i'm going to call
you and say is there anything you need
today
and i'm going to do that for a few weeks
until it just becomes a rhythm
and if i'm not able to help that day i'm
not gonna call i'm gonna remind them hey
we're here if you need anything
and then we're gonna go from there and
they may think your in-laws may think
they're
are doing good by not calling the
brothers
for some twisted way they may think that
that's just the best thing to do
but i don't tell you is going to war and
getting angry will solve nothing it'll
just make this painful thing so much
more hurtful
it sounds like a desperate need
of a of an in-person conversation and if
you can't get that then you can't get
that you can mourn and grieve it and ah
and i'm gonna call
my in-laws every day
right but i do get man i hate this for
you and i do get the dividing you're not
really one of the kids you're over here
you're
and some of that's going to be you
imagining that someone's going to be
super real that
sister-in-law's
circling up and making this her whatever
you know what i mean i'm just not gonna
get in a
competition and a fight with people
trying to help somebody who's dying i'm
just not right what's the prognosis on
this cancer
um
dude and that's the thing we've been
getting mixed information um and i'm not
necessarily sure
if it's the doctors trying to give them
false hope or what it what it is or if
it's the sister trying to
to bury the brother like pat it for the
brothers
but they told her 12 to 18 months but
then when they did the surgery
supposedly they got like most of the
tumor out
um so i'm not i really don't know okay
so i'm sort of like 12 to 18 months in
my mind yeah and that's where you're
going to protect yourself
and that might be data supported and it
might not be
that's where a clear meeting that people
somebody bring a calendar
that you can pass along to everybody or
start a google calendar or whatever it's
going to be a way that everybody can
keep the
the appointments in schedule the meals
needed in schedule it just needs some
organization here and it needs some
communication
and if you get a clear sense that they
don't want your involvement it will hurt
in a major way
and that will be their issue not yours
right
so we're kind of in a hiatus right now
where she has like a few weeks off
before her next
like
treatment regimen
um
so we're trying to take an impromptu
like vacation
um
just to spend time with her
so i hate to like put a damp in the
vacation mode but like i feel like this
stuff needs to be talked about would you
call like a separate meeting because
it's really hard to get everybody
together all at once
um
i i i don't i don't
not talking about cancer
is not gonna make it go away
right not talking about the elephant in
a room
isn't gonna make it go away so if i'm
you here's how i would have that
conversation
i would say
hey we're all getting ready to go on a
mini vacation and looking forward to it
there's a big elephant in the room
mother-in-law how would you would you
you want us to talk to you about it how
do you want us to address this you want
us to just pretend it's not real for 48
hours do you want us to connect with you
like how do you want us to walk
alongside you and let her speak into it
right now she's got three kids and three
spouses worth of people trying to solve
her
trying to help in ways that they think
is the best way and nobody's asked mom
how can we help
and mom may say the best way you can
help me
sons
is you all love your your spouses you
all go to work hug your kill my
grandkids and i'll call you if i need
something
daughter i need you here every step of
the way and she gets to do that
and you can choose to take that
personally and say well i wish you'd
asked me or you can choose to say cool
she is a woman who has got terminal
brain cancer and
she gets to call out how she wants to be
helped but instead of a bunch of people
making a bunch of side decisions about
how they best help mom bring mom into
the conversation let her speak directly
into how we can best love her
let dad do that too
and hopefully that will solve a lot of
these downstream effects and it's going
to be on you and your husband
to choose i'm not going to get my
feelings hurt if they if they request
sister not me
it's going to hurt but i'm gonna choose
that to let them have the care they
wanna have
ugh that'll be hard
i'm gonna choose and i take this stuff
personally even though it's a mess even
though it's the most personal situation
i've been through
and i hate this for you man a
powerful matriarch that gets brain
cancer it's just devastating for the
whole family
that's where clarity clarity
direction as much in-person
communication or zoom conversation is
possible staying off texts and as much
clarity clarity clarity clarity clarity
i keep saying that over and over
it tends to just
it just makes the path so much so much
easier to walk on
heartbroken for you lisa let's get
everybody in the room asap and have this
conversation
and then we'll go from there thank you
so much be right back on the doctor john
dewine
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not and how you can get back
on the road of being whole and well
listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndeloney.com and
get your copy of redefining anxiety
today
all right let's take one more call let's
go to michelle in boston hey michelle
what's going on
hi john how are you good how are you
good good
um so my question today um
is how do i work with my husband to help
him battle um his severe severe trauma
from his childhood um
and the ptsd and anxiety and depression
that he's left with today
even with one of his abusers still in
his life
and then also
how do we connect on a spiritual level
um
for his healing when some
a lot of his trauma came from people who
were
related to his church and
religious people
and
that genre
i feel like he holds back because of it
yeah of course we can't
and we can't really connect on that
level but even just so
even so he's just in such a bad place in
his life and
this person is still around and
[Music]
we just seem like stuck
yeah so is your husband going through
treatment of some sort is he is he on a
healing journey or is he just getting
through every day just grinding it out
he is on a healing journey but to be
completely honest he was forced to um
a couple years ago his body kind of
turned on him
and he
started what we thought were allergic
reactions turned into panic attacks
and his anxiety was taking over his body
um
so it it basically ate its way out and
now it's a it's a daily battle for him
um he used to be completely honest
before me he used drugs and alcohol to
of course yeah um why why is
why is an abuser still in his life
um
he has a
narcissistic mother okay she's uh did
she abuse him as a kid
physically abused as a kid he was also
sexually abused
by
other
others so did mom know about that
growing up
not growing up um but she was very
physically abusive to him um after
her after
she got divorced from their father
um
probably from like five
on
he was physically abused
very badly um but she's so narcissistic
uh and gaslighting that she
denies it um
even ever using a belt on him or
anything and he's he's a very in a very
lonely place in his head you know um so
imagine this
imagine
there is a bear
that
eats
part of your arm and leg as a as a kid
as a child right
just gnaws it off blood mess bones
breaking all of it
and then
that bear
just lives in your living room
forever
right
your body would never heal and you'll
just die young
right and until he decides to he's got
to
create
significant
strong
disconnected boundaries from his mom
so that he until he gets that bear out
of his living room
and creates somewhat of a safe place
where his heart can stop racing and his
head can stop going hey she's right
there she's right there
right
he's not gonna get it
yeah and that could make it worse
that can make it worse
because then the communication is
electronic
and that gaslighting
and she's the worst exactly
and so he needs to take his phone out
and block her today
no more comments for birthday too so
well happy birthday
right he just he just uh wrote to me a
little while ago saying he did call her
and
he
i feel like he's my
child because i'm like i'm trying to
hold up the boundaries he hey he is he
you've he's become your kid
and your mom and that's not a way to
hold on to a marriage
and my guess is you're getting exhausted
and you love him like crazy and you're
getting exhausted
because i'm also i'm i'm scared for my
kids yeah of course they really they
really love their grandmother and um
but i mean it's all part of the game you
know grandmother realize that her love
isn't real a bear
yes
that tried to kill your husband
she does not get access to your kids for
a long time
and listen my kids love people that give
them candy i'm still discriminating
against about who they're involved with
right right
and you've got this picture and it's an
incredible one of your mother-in-law
coming around and being this awesome
grandma
and we all go play that is over
it's it's really creepy yeah
it's scary and it's over
and you have to draw that boundary and
your husband's got to draw that boundary
and when it comes to spiritual
connection it wasn't a bear
it was a
a
firing squad
it was a torture chamber for your
husband
and so any sort of faith healing
is going to have to be unbraided from
the people that hurt him
and so
trying to connect with him in the
torture chamber is going to be a
challenge for a season
[Music]
does that make sense
yeah
and you're going to feel lonely because
you want to connect with him on a
spiritual level and you want to raise
your kids in a certain way
and he's going to continue to remember
that's where i was sexually abused
that's not safe yeah we can't
he can't even go back to his
we where we grew up he can't even go
back of course of course it's been
slowly happening for a long time and
um
he's
he he just
i'm realizing like i do a lot of
research and i try to find things and i
just sent him a thing about triggers
with his ptsd because
he goes we don't even know what sets him
off
some days um but i know it could be
literally anything it could be a song it
could be a
um
a way someone something said a smell of
this or that so
you know he goes into these
breakdowns and has a full-on panic
attack
and um
you know well i'm i'm just trying to get
him out you know help him out and help
him
through it and so here's the thing
here's the thing
number one i'm so sorry michelle
this is so hard
it's so hard
and you are a strong strong woman he's
lucky to have you in his life
and you are also
his mom now too
and you are trying to solve this and you
can't solve it you can't fix him
i'm telling you right now 1 000
chance not a doubt in my mind
if he wants to heal from this trauma
he can no question about it
it will be a gauntlet he will walk
through hell and back and he will need
somebody strong like you by his side
but he's got to do the walk on his own
you can't lay in this bed with him you
can hold his hand while he's in it but
you can't do it for him
and if he wants to get to the bottom of
vanderkolt says trauma is not what
happened
it is our body's response in the present
to things that happen in the past
right so until he decides i want to
regain control of my body in the present
i cannot heal the fact that my mom the
one woman on on the planet
who was supposed to take care of me
abused the crap out of me
i can't fix i can't change that
i can't change the fact that the one
safe place i should be able to go to is
with my faith community
took my innocence away they stole that
from me
they sexually abused me
you can't change that what i can change
is how my body and the present responds
to things that happen in the past
and that's what healing trauma is
but he's got to decide that
right and you can't make it it's so hard
with the mother mother i know that's why
she's got you got to get the bear out of
the living room first
the body's never going to heal it can't
she keeps biting him scratching him
right and then at the same time your kid
hurt your kids are on that beer's back
having the time of their life just
playing playing playing
right you got to get that bear out of
the living room she has cashed in
she's out
she doesn't get to be mom for a season
man and then she and then she turns that
around on us
it doesn't matter she is an abuser
i don't care what she says she gets no
votes
she gets no votes in my house i don't
care what she turns around i okay what
she says she is does not exist
does that make sense
yeah
it's say it say it she doesn't get a
vote in my house anymore
you're right she doesn't get a vote in
my house anymore say it with conviction
you're a powerful
mom
right would you would you let some
stranger some strange man just come live
in your living room
and your husband walks in and he would
just punch your husband in the face and
they'd hand your kids some candy would
you allow that
right now no you wouldn't you'd go to
war for your husband you'd go to war for
those kids
and just because it's it's his mom
doesn't make it it makes it more evil
not less it makes it more painful more
hurtful
and your husband feels trapped and the
moment he unplugs from mom will be the
first day he starts to get well
okay
because his body is continuing to fight
and fight and flee
and run and freeze
from a threat that he's been under for
30 something years
right
and it's time to get the bear out of the
living room
and you can heal from a faith community
for sure
but he's gonna have to walk through hell
to get there
it's gonna be hard and it may look
different than you and your fantasy and
you're in in the world you the picture
you have it may look different
ultimately
right
right because they stopped
yeah my best friend is his sister and
his so
um and in the past
the sisters have been used as weapons by
the mom so i don't ever want to hear
about your mother-in-law ever again
right
i know i know yeah okay and tell the
sister tell your best friend
mom's not welcome here anymore oh my
gosh are you serious yes not welcome
she's an abuser
i for sure i'm not letting my little
kids around her and
i am going to do everything i can to
keep my husband out of that woman's
presence
so that
his body can finally recognize that he's
safe
and i'm going to go back
to being his lover
his partner in life his best friend i'm
gonna stop being his mom
i'm gonna quit being his mother
and i'm gonna create a well home a safe
home
with him he's gonna play a part in this
and he's gonna decide
i'm worth being well and i'm worth being
completely plugged in and connected with
my kids i'm worth being completely
plugged in and having a reckless wild
love with my wife
and he's gonna have to learn how to do
that
because the first woman didn't love him
she abused him the faith community
didn't love him it abused him
his sisters are a mess
and it's going to be tempting for you to
keep punishing mom to keep going back to
mom i don't care about her she doesn't
get a vote
she's done
and this is hard i'd love love love for
you to give us a shout back and i'd love
to talk to your husband
both of y'all on the phone at the same
time that'd be awesome i'd love to just
listen to his story and walk alongside
him
but remember these three things
you cannot fix him you can love him you
can stay physically connected to him you
can hold him you can look him in the eye
and say i love you
but you can't fix him
he has to decide i want to be well
and by the way he's not broken
he needs healing
he's hurt he's not broken
second thing is get mother-in-law out
she gets no more votes done get the bear
out of the house
number three i want you and your husband
you've got to you michelle
you've got to put this fantasy picture
down of what you've created of this
perfect life it's different now
it's different
i want you and him to go co-create what
this thing's gonna look like you're
gonna do it season by season by season
what's the next six months gonna look
like for us is it summer is it winter is
it spring or or or fall what's it gonna
look like
are we gonna slowly rebuild this thing
and we're gonna paint a picture together
and it sounds all cheesy it's not
we all have to excavate everything and
rebuild something totally new
that doesn't include mother-in-law
ah michelle he's so lucky to have you
he's so lucky to have you
thank you so so much for your call
oh
james kelly this is a hard show man
people are hurting hurt and hurting
man
man
this uh man we're gonna
for my favorite songwriters in the world
he lives here in nashville
today's song of the day man
so listen to these lyrics it's from
andrew peterson
the name of the song is don't you want
to thank somebody don't you want to
thank someone
can't you feel it in your bones as
something isn't right here
something you've always known but you
don't know why
because every time the sun goes down we
face another night here waiting for the
world to spin around just to survive
but when you see the morning sun burning
through a silver mist
don't you want to thank someone
don't you ever wonder why in spite of
all that's wrong here there's still so
much that goes so right and beauty
abounds
because sometimes you just walk outside
and the air is full of song here and the
thunder rolls and the baby's eyes and
the rain comes down
don't you want to thank someone for this
in spite of all the hurt and all the
pain folks don't forget to look for
beauty
there's more good than there is wrong i
promise you i promise you
thank you so much we'll be right back
the next show with the dr john de la
michelle
[Music]